foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by best-selling author
Ken Coleman this hour and we are taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you ready to go George I hope so you
just finished up the Ken Coleman show
yeah I got a lot of juice right now and
I feel like you need to get your energy
level up oh boy okay thanks Coach Ken
just a little bit more a little bit more
energy for these line folks thank you
for that you're very very calm because
you're the the
quintessential professional underneath
it's like the duck underwater you know
the legs removable you and I always have
fun together with our callers so I'm
excited let's let's do it all right Abby
is kicking us off in Green Bay Wisconsin
Abby welcome to the show
hi guys how are you doing doing great
how can we help
yeah
um so I recently got married about two
months ago oh congratulations
thank you thank you
um my husband and I are both graduating
from college
um this spring
um no debt or anything where we have
about seven Grand saved up and um we're
looking to do a 15-month missionary
program
um and we're just wondering if maybe we
should
put it off here and get full-time jobs
and work a year and then have to leave
them or if we just do the the program
right away
um and then get full-time jobs
afterwards I am also in the military so
that would cover all of our like
expenses
um like insurance and that stuff but at
the at the program it's free room
um and food and that kind of thing so
there's not many expenses okay I'm just
curious you're in the military full-time
or in the guard I mean and how are you
going to be able to take off for
Missions work
yeah I'm in the Navy Reserve um so it's
just one weekend a month and then two
weeks in the summer I would have my
training and and you'd be able to pay
your bills you're not have you don't
have I know you have no debt but you
have plenty of money all expenses
covered while you're doing this Mission
work
correct yeah and how long is it also get
a stipend um 15 months so it'd be this
may to um August of 2024. yeah well if
if I'm you I would not do the route of
step into a real career move like I'm
I'm now on the ladder that I want to be
on and do that for a year and then all
of a sudden take 15 months off
I'm not saying that's wrong I don't
think this is a right or wrong because
you can always come back to that work
too so I want to give the other side of
it this is just my personal opinion if
I'm you I go and do it now I think it's
a great adventure I think it's going to
change your life in a positive way and
financially you're able to do it I would
do it now and knock that out and really
be able to soak in that
and have that experience and then when
you're done with that you've got the
timeline and you can plan for entering
into the workforce after that mission
that's how I would do it but I'm also
quick to say George I don't think
there's a a right or a wrong here
especially because they've got financial
piece to be able to do that yeah you
have the foundation financially so the
decision come for me have you got this
approved with the reserves
yes they're cool with you being gone for
15 months
correct it's it's still Stateside it's
in Colorado so I was still um and
there's no funding needed for this
Mission work
it's just automatically covered
yes okay and there's no the stipend will
just cover your your bare bones expenses
um yes okay plus plus her pay from the
guard correct
yes so the gargle tape for all of our um
the expenses that we need and then the
stipend because we've just put in
savings or like travel and that sort of
thing I mean that this is a very rare
scenario where there's no risk here the
yeah the boxes are checked for me and if
this is something you're very passionate
about uh then I'd go for it I'd also
have a plan of what you want to do when
you're back because it's a it's going to
be a weird world coming back after 15
months of mission work into the
workforce
right do you both know a certain amount
then we can head out there well it just
depends on your expenses and so if you
guys can basically live on nothing and
you don't have any major expenses you
need to cover outside of your stipend
and what the reserves are giving you
then you're in good shape
do you both know the path that you want
to pursue professionally
ah yes yes so what are you studying yeah
um I'm studying uh geology and my
husband is studying software engineering
so he's going to come back and and be a
developer work in the tech space
yes and what will you be doing
cool that sounds pretty specific to me
yeah so because your stateside
because you've got all your expenses
covered I would I would be thinking
almost from day one
what does the path look like what do we
need to do above and beyond our existing
educational qualifications what
relationship building connections uh
interviewing start interviewing I would
say I you know I would say a good
eight to ten months out ahead of time
and telling them what you're doing and
and you know and finding out what the
market looks like I just wouldn't wait
you know until cold turkey the 15-month
mission thing is up and now all of a
sudden we're going to try to re-enter uh
even though financially you could do
that I just you know I want to see you
planning while you're serving I think
that's my challenge to you but this is
great and um and I must say I don't want
to skip over the fact that
this is the best of us
Abby and her husband I mean this is this
is what makes the world a better place
somebody a young couple like this who
are saying you know what our
professional future is in front of us
but we want to go serve people and we
have the financial freedom to be able to
do it I just think it's going to make a
huge difference in their lives going
forward absolutely and it's one of the
reasons the baby steps works for
everyone and if you want that kind of
freedom because you are passionate about
a certain organization or a certain
field and you're going man if I could
just get there well having no payments
really frees you up to have those kinds
of options yeah and so I encourage
everyone regardless of what your goals
are to live debt free to have an
emergency fund because when this
opportunity does come up it becomes a
no-brainer and you go this is the
opportunity of a lifetime we can take it
because we don't owe lenders money so we
can go do this thing over here for no
pay for very little pay because we're
passionate about it without worrying
about the bills yeah you know I I love
this idea so much and and of course
they're doing this on their own from a
volunteer in a Ministry standpoint but
you know I'd love to abolish the Student
Loan program the federal student loan
program
and what I would love to do is is to
take the taxpayer dollars or the money
that that the federal government has
made all the years through student loans
and it would be fun to fund a year of
service project
of just to kind of uh we're gonna pay
for your expenses you don't have to
worry about a thing you're not paying
your salary but food board uh all that
we're going to take care of it for every
young person before they ever enter into
the professional World they got to serve
their fellow countrymen
for 12 months
I just think that's a worthy Endeavor
that could change society right I really
do this is quite division yeah I'm here
for it well way to go Abby we're proud
of you thank you for your service more
of your calls coming up triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life your
money your work your purpose and help
you get that breakthrough this is the
Ramsay show
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Ramsay personality and
co-host of smart money happy hour joined
by the host of the Ken Coleman show you
guessed it Ken Coleman himself uh what
is a guy got to do to uh have a chance
to uh imbibe with you and Rachel that is
Coveted territory and here's the truth
we had John deloney on for a quick
segment and never again have we had a
guest so the fact that he ruined it for
everyone yeah well that's great he took
over you know it's my show can't have
that okay all right well maybe one day
Ken dream big maybe I can just sit there
in the studio and drink off camera shoot
for the moon and you'll land amongst the
Stars I kid I don't do that I'm just
gonna have a glass of milk I love that a
full glass of milk are you a whole milk
guy no two percent okay but in my car
yeah yeah I try to be healthy I've
switched to oat milk if anyone's
wondering nobody was and then they're
not surprised though oat milk yep that's
not milk it's fair it's just water plus
oats again water and oats doesn't make
milk no one is listening to the show
anymore can they've all tuned out well I
think it's actually now people are
weighing in they're like yeah I agree
with Ken that's not milk that's fair
this is what people want to do they want
to argue if you want to call in and talk
about milk we're here for it but we'd
rather help you you know with lots of
help you make more money I'm here today
to help you make more money that's like
my role how do you make the phones are
going to be ringing like a Telethon at
this point well because you know what
Dave has said for decades your income is
the greatest wealth building tool you
have and I'm here to help you make more
income all right so let's take those
calls you want to make more money I'm
your huckleberry let's do it and it
helps with the baby steps as well it
propels you it helps the baby steps
let's go increase that income more money
baby I'm your guy let's go all right
let's go to the phones Devin is up next
in Fort Worth Texas Devin welcome to the
show
hey guys hey how are you all doing can
you hear me okay yeah loud and clear
okay good good I was having a little bit
of issue so I just kind of stayed put I
was like
those are just the voices in your head
don't worry about it press through this
exactly yeah tell me to make more money
so I can buy milk come on man there we
go
so what's your question so I I actually
as I said I didn't realize actually Ken
Coleman was on the show today so I
actually thought I had a two-part uh one
kind of a silly question and the other
one's a little bit more deep but the
first one I wanted to kind of run by was
uh I know ran the whole Ramsey uh
financial piece and everything like that
I know it's all about no credit card at
all but I've actually I've never heard
this address and so I was just kind of
curious on what y'all's opinion on it so
I have one card that I ended up paying
off and gone done but I didn't realize
in the process of paying it off that I
had a minimum auto pay draft on it and
it put a negative balance on the card
and it's not a huge thing because it's
not a whole lot of money but I'm just
kind of curious to know is there any
benefit at all to that like as far as I
guess like maybe uh I know the rewards
points thing was a huge deal but why
don't you tell us what's the number
what's the negative amount on your
credit card
35 bucks so you had a zero balance then
it auto paid 35 and so now they
technically owe you 35 dollars
right yeah it was a it was a so it was a
62 dollar and some change balance left I
made the payment got it done but I
didn't I I guess in the process of doing
that somehow it was still stuck on the
auto pay because I was wanting to ensure
that I wouldn't at least miss a minimum
payment and it put a negative balance on
that because I guess it ended up
processing that uh within the time spent
about taking it all yeah I've never
heard of this and I can't think of any
benefit you would get from the I don't
think this is like a life hack that you
crack some code with the credit card
companies right and I don't know how it
would affect your credit score having
the negative balance where they owe you
it doesn't make sense I would just
contact the company and say Hey listen
there was an auto pay I have a negative
balance can you reinstate it and credit
me back that money back to zero and then
I close the account
either that or I guess just transfer it
back to my checking account yeah just
transfer back to where you you owe them
nothing they owe you nothing yeah and
then disclose it it's not doing you any
favors at this point
yeah okay so that's cool I was just kind
of curious now I don't think I've ever
heard of that question that's why I was
curious to ask
um really the other thing I kind of
wanted to get an opinion on though
mainly is
um I man I gotta be honest I'm 30 years
old I've got a family and I have never
felt like I've had a direction as far as
a career goes with my life I've done
like a lot of different things and I you
know at this point I just like I guess
I'm just wanting to know what kind of
mindset like what I should what kind of
things should I be thinking about like
as far as like
um and to be honest I I don't have any
like formal education or anything I just
have always known that
um no matter what I do no matter what
that is I just want to make sure that I
always take care of my family yeah well
you're going to do that you're gonna do
that so here's here's here's high level
here's the high level answer and then
I'll ask you to shoot some ideas at me a
high level answer to how can I figure
out what my professional Direction uh
what it what that is in my life is very
simple
you got to figure out what you do well
these are your talents
and then you got to figure out what what
work you actually enjoy doing
and then you got to figure out what
results motivate you those three areas
allow for someone to get self-aware and
then when I get self-aware
as it relates to well I'm good at doing
these types of things I enjoy doing this
type of work and these results get me
excited when I think about them I'm
going to get out of bed you don't have
to motivate me I'm motivated to produce
these type of results what that does is
that begins to spit out ideas and and
what it does is all that Clarity makes
me confident when the ideas pop up I go
oh this makes a lot of sense so I want
to put you to the test really quick
uh what have you wondered about I think
you've probably spent more time
wondering about a certain direction than
maybe certain other ideas there's
probably one or two ideas that have
always popped up for you and maybe
because of fear or doubt or Pride you
just haven't done anything with them so
why don't you just tell me what is
something that you wonder about on a
regular basis but you just haven't ever
pursued it
helping people okay well we're under
we're at pretty high level uh who who do
we want to help what people do you
wonder or think about helping describe
those people maybe their problem or
their desire
um I guess in a sense
um I guess I guess man I guess I'm
trying to break it down between like
what they would need help with I get I
guess that's the part that I've never
I guess I've never thought about exactly
what it is that
I would want to exactly help them with
all right let me put it this way let me
put this way you're overthinking and I
need you to stop thinking okay you need
you need to feel this answer all right
don't try to explain it to me if I gave
you a great chunk of money for 30 days
more than you're making now and I said
all you've got to do
Devin is just find a way to help people
for 30 days of work
who would you go start help how would
you help it forget the who what would
you be doing you get to choose
your choice you just say Ken I would be
doing this I'd be helping this way how
would I help these people what's the
answer
um
I guess I would help them to
achieve what it is that
man I guess I would help them achieve
what it is that they want to accomplish
as far as their goals go right now I
guess is where I think about that yeah
but here's what happened the entire
audience heard you think your way
through that sentence you started and
I'm telling you what was going on behind
the scenes in your head is there are
certain people that you find yourself
going I'd love to help this kind of
person
now you're real high level right now
which is I want to help people achieve
what they want well do you want them to
help them achieve it in the area of
physical uh nutrition exercise you want
to help them financially do you want to
help them professionally do you want to
help them spiritually do you want to
help them relationally you don't have to
answer that right now I'm not going to
put you on the spot anymore but hang on
the line I'm going to give you two tools
I'm going to give you my get clear
career assessment which will allow you
to answer those questions easier because
we ask them of you you're gonna get a
detailed report on what you do best what
you love to do and what motivates you
and then some really good ideas and I'm
going to give you the book from paycheck
to purpose which is the guide to climb
the mountain after the assessment tells
you what mountain you want to climb hang
on the line we'll get that to you thanks
for the call Devin appreciate it Devin
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
by their
wash faction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you need a
breakthrough you need a second opinion a
third opinion on your money your work
your purpose we are here for you this
hour Aiden joins us up next in Atlanta
Aiden welcome to the show how you doing
hey how's it going good good how are you
good I just man I've been so eager to
get some kind of professional advice
from someone and maybe the best we got
well let me tell you you have arrived at
the right what is a consummate today I
don't know I mean we're Pros aren't we
George that's self-proclaimed
what's going on
I'm so just just real quick I'm 19 years
old I work for the fire department of my
city and they lowered the age limit so I
was able to be very fortunate be very
blessed to get in a career so young
right out of high school that's great um
I saved up quite a good bit before I
moved out of my mother's house and I
you know saved and saved but I still
ended up making you know the the young
foolish mistake of getting a place and
getting a car
um because in my head at the time I was
you know thinking well I want to stay
ahead of my age group I want to stay
ahead of my peers so why not get a place
with a mortgage and why not get a car
that I've always wanted
um and so I've accrued about 150 000 in
debt I've been able to maintain
responsibility and and continue to make
payments on it but I still really want
my biggest life goal is to have a legacy
and create generational wealth and
really just continue to stay ahead I was
just wondering what your thoughts and
opinions on what I should do next is
what's the 150 in debt break that down
so 125 is for this townhouse that I'm
staying in so that's your mortgage 100
uh the mortgage
um it's I believe uh 10.50 a month okay
and what's the other 25
the other
so it's 150 the other part of it is the
car note
um and it the car that I got was I
believe around 30 okay and I'm making
payments on that as well and it's about
uh five six hundred every month yeah
basically um
I'm sorry what's your income
um I would say around 48 49 000 gross
okay
and here's what you told me you said you
want to create generational wealth but
your goals and your actions have so far
been misaligned and so I need to know
which one do you actually want
I know I can't have my cake and eat it
too
um but I definitely want well you said
you wanted you want to get ahead of your
peers that's different than generational
wealth getting ahead with your peers
means looking good which we've succeeded
at so far generational wealth means
we're gonna get out of debt and have an
inheritance to leave to our children's
children that's what that means to me
and so comparatively to your income this
is a lot of car
for a 19 year old
yes and my car is not worth this and I'm
a net worth millionaire and I'm going
the hoof for a 19 year old to step into
that that's a lot of car so what is the
car worth today
um as far as reselling it it's been
there's been a shortage on the make and
model that I got and that's why I wanted
it because I knew it was going to go
pretty fast which means you could sell
it for a pretty penny
right they're worth a little bit more so
how much could you sell it for
top dollar today uh probably 38. okay
and you owe how much left on the loan
um 30 I think it's like 30 and some
change okay so it would leave you with
eight grand
which you could pay for a used car it's
going to be a whole lot dinkier than the
one you're driving now
of course that puts you a whole lot
closer to becoming a net worth
millionaire and having generational
wealth that just leaves you with the
mortgage right
yes sir and then making 50k and you're
19 it's going to continue to go up how
quickly could you pay off the mortgage
and begin investing for the future
um pretty soon I plan on picking up
extra work for another ambulance company
that's what
I wanted to hear I mean at your age you
want to get ahead George is right you're
working more hours man and in your world
firefighter ENT all that you can get a
lot of overtime presumably correct
yes they they do a lot of different
bonuses and and different pop-ups here
and there for games and stuff like that
and transporting patients long distances
fantastic um and I'm and I know I'm very
happy and fortunate to be in this field
because I know I have pretty well uh
Security in that field well yeah you're
going to get a great retirement
situation there but then you're going to
follow the baby steps and and once you
pay this condo off for a town home or
whatever my friend that is you getting
way ahead of your peers and that you
have a cash property that you own and
you're investing 15 and you got your
fireman benefits and you got overtime
possibilities and you have promotional
opportunities I mean it stands to
believe you could move pretty high up in
the fire uh Department uh by just the
simple fact that you started so young so
you've got a great future ahead of you
but you got to really listen to what
George said I mean he really challenged
you on the mindset side of this which is
what it takes to win with money
perspective
changes my belief and believe changes my
actions so George is challenging you
with a proper financial perspective and
then you begin to see oh I believe that
he's right I believe that this is what I
should do and then before you know it
you're living differently acting
differently and that's the result amen
so Aiden do you have any savings
um I do have a thousand put away okay um
I know that being so close paycheck to
paycheck has have already created me
like a good deal of anxiety which is why
I want to get more work because I don't
like the feeling of being in this you
know predicament and um you know just
watching the content on YouTube that's
available and like just hovering over as
we speak like the whole Financial Peace
University because my mom did it and
she's almost done with her mortgage and
it's awesome of that nature hey can I
give you a an instant uh ladder to a pay
raise
can I do that for you sell the car today
sell the car today go get yourself an
eight thousand dollar car and go get
your roommate so now all of a sudden if
we get a roommate and let's just say we
split the mortgage because you've got a
roommate renting with you and you charge
600 bucks yeah I mean
so now you freed up a 600 plus the car
payment so now you just got a twelve
hundred dollar raise
right that's before overtime my friend
and now we can start building that three
to six months emergency fund then we can
begin investing 15 whatever's left don't
forget the margin there's no anxiety
dude I feel more afraid just talking
about this with you Aiden
and so the question is and this is a
hard thing I'm not saying it's easy but
you've got to put the blinders on and go
I don't really care what my friends
think about what I drive because they're
going to see you driving that other car
and go dude what happened this ride
stinks you had such a cool car and you
went I'm trying to create generational
wealth and if they don't get that that's
fine and and I'm glad you bring that up
George Aiden can I give you another
little mini PEC talk uh George you know
the numbers on student loan the average
student loan you probably know this
wants you to add to it but I know that
the average college student is spending
almost six years
in trying to attain that degree so I
just want to give you a little
perspective that here you are working
right now
I've got another five years before they
ever exit college and then they got the
student loan hanging around what's the
average yeah 38 000 I think is the
average amount so six years
to get out of school and then you walk
away on average with about forty
thousand dollars in debt and Aiden
that's not you so if you start feeling
like oh I'm worried about what
everybody's going to say about me I'd
run that reality through your head one
time and as you get older you
automatically start caring less and less
about what other people think but if you
do that at 19 dude you're gonna be light
years ahead
and that is the the best encouragement I
can give you because I remember being
your age and I was a knucklehead man I
was spending every dime I was making for
my jobs I was trying to I was buying
gear trying to impress people and then I
realized no one actually cares they're
all so focused on themselves and their
own insecurity and they're doing exactly
what you're doing and when you realize
we're all just running our own race as
insecure human beings you know just do
what's right for you yeah and remember
20 years from now Aiden you're probably
gonna walk out in your backyard your
neighbor will see you in a robe and tube
socks and flip-flops and you just don't
care we're all gonna be lame dads one
day just lean into it my friend hey
we're gonna gift you one year of
financial base University so you can be
like Mom maybe go through it with her
it'll be a good time so hang on the line
we're going to gift you Financial Peace
University watch all the lessons do the
budget and you'll be on your path to
being a millionaire my friend
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show if
you're a new listener to the show and
you want a deeper dive into all the
things that we talk about especially the
Ramsay baby steps our team has made a
really easy tool for you just go to
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
and we will help you figure out the next
best step for your financial Journey the
buttons right there as soon as you hit
the website ramsaysolutions.com click on
get started and if you're planning on
moving anytime soon that's fantastic I'm
excited for you but let's be real in
most places around the country you'll
still be facing high home prices and
interest rates aren't exactly returning
to those record lows but here's the good
news it doesn't make home ownership
impossible if you want to buy or sell
you've got to make sure you're
financially ready and you've got to have
a trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk you through this not a
family friend who just got their license
last month not someone who does Real
Estate as a part-time Hobby
you need to work with a pro who's a true
expert in the local market knows how to
negotiate strong deals so you can find
those people these High Caliber Ramsay
trusted agents through our endorsed
local provider program and since we vet
the agents from around the country
you're gonna have the best support
whether you're moving from Florida to
Alaska or buying your first home
somewhere in between just go to
ramsaysolutions.com agent to find a
Ramsay trusted real estate agent today
that's ramsesolutions.com
agent are you settled in your new home
we're very settled I could not be more
settled yeah and you used a uh a Ramsey
trusted out there and got the right
house in a neighborhood close by so
you're loving life and it's so important
because they understand they run the
comps they know everything about the
neighborhoods they know how to Market it
they know how to Stage it I mean they
are true marketing experts yeah and so
to do this on your own I've seen people
do the for sale by owner where they've
got the sign of the yard and they want
to save on the realtor fees so I'm gonna
do this myself right someone will drive
by and give me top dollar and they're
photos look like their toddler took it
on like a Nikon Coolpix and I'm going
what are you doing I can see the litter
box in the phone yes see you're right uh
what are you and Whitney doing tonight
you want Stacy and I to come over see
the new house you know uh we'll we'll
think about it okay yeah all right we'll
see what the plans are I got no control
over the plans as you know Ken Stacy
runs the calendar in your house you
might as well be a professional bull
fighter the way you evaded that question
that was good George we do love the
colemans we have had a many a personal
interaction yeah going out to dinner
that's
oh
George and I are tight
ens
Interruption you
well we're colleagues Ken you remind me
of that every day it's a good word but
we me and Ken actually sit next to each
other like in our cubes and we have a
great time truth be known to paint the
full picture I sit between you and John
deloney so I would appreciate your
prayers thoughts and prayers send them
my way some people call that a devil
blessing
some people call it a nightmare double
dose of meds that's what I need oh all
right all right let's get to the phones
and if you've got a question you can
jump in at triple eight eight two five
five two two five uh Lori I believe is
in Toledo did I pronounce that right
Lori
that is corrected as Lori good how can
we help today
all right thank you for taking my call
George and Ken all right so just a quick
back story I previously worked 10 years
for a private Urology office we were
going through a merger with a local
hospital
uh during that merger I was diagnosed
with breast cancer and
I chose not to go back when I was off
for my double mastectomy there were
several reasons for not for deciding not
to go back and during that time which
was two and a half years ago I took a
job working from home for a large health
insurance company
since then I have doubled my income as
well as I have moved up within the
company
the position I have now
um I've been doing very well in
um however I'm currently on short-term
disability I've been off for five weeks
and have another week off
I had one of my previous co-workers from
my other department that I came from
that I had just moved up from reach out
to me last night and stating that there
was some layoffs that were going on and
several people within that department
was laid off
so my concern is
um at this point I don't know if this is
a mass layoff within the company or if
it's just specific departments that have
been affected by this and the company of
course is one big umbrella so it's
really hard to determine I did reach out
to my supervisor by text this morning
just to say hey just to let you know
I'll be back on the 13th
um and but she hasn't even responded to
that so I guess I'm at that point do I
write this out I don't really want to
give up the working from home at this
time or as well as the pay because I've
doubled my income by working for this
company so I'm not sure if I should
write this out or if I should kind of
keep my eyes and ears open for something
else what's your financial situation if
they called today and laid you off
what's your reality what would you have
to do financially
financially I know I would need to look
for another position or to go you know
somewhere else
um I I can tell you that between
my husband and I we have more than
doubled our incomes in the last two
years
um but you know we were kind of you know
playing that whole thing credit card
game that we were doing and kind of got
ourselves into some credit card debt so
what's the current household income well
what I want to do really quick George I
want to get I want to focus on something
I want George to walk you through the
financial part but I just want I want
you professionally I want to answer that
part really quickly
um okay
you need to be looking and connecting
right now but I would not leave
unless so I would ride it out but
writing it out does not mean just well
I'm going to go I'm just going to do my
thing and just wait to see what happens
no I'm going to start connecting
and looking at the same time I'm looking
I'm connecting and the more I look the
more I realize I need to connect and
what you're going to do is you're going
to put some feelers out and it's a very
simple message you have to worry about
how it comes across because you're going
to be basically look there's been some
layoffs and I'm just kind of seeing
what's out there uh not not a guarantee
that I'm going to get laid off so I
would be doing that now okay but don't
leave unless in the looking in the
connecting something better comes along
then it's a no-brainer okay but you are
looking and connecting and then George
will tell you what you're doing while
you're still collecting that paycheck to
to give yourself more margin so while
you're doing homework on the career side
I want you to start looking at your
financial numbers so what is the
household income today
um our income is about 120 000 a year
and how much debt do you have
uh
um excluding the house um it's over a
hundred thousand okay what kind of debt
is a hundred thousand
um it is credit card debt one vehicle
and
um credit credit cards
so more credit cards
uh yeah there's there's quite a few
credit cards um and then of course
student loan debt okay well how about
this live your life like you're gonna
get laid off tomorrow and let that drive
how you look at your finances because
right now you've been living la vida
loca and now we've got to go to fire
mode and go oh my gosh there's a storm
coming we need to get rid of as much
debt as possible yeah we are shoveling
the water out of this boat so it doesn't
sink and so that would be my plan of
attack is to and if you want to save up
a bunch of money right now for the next
month until you know more that's okay if
you need to weather a storm did you just
say you have it did I hear you say that
what did you say I'm sorry what what was
that I thought as George was talking you
said we have or we had and I wanted to
know what you were saying well we we
actually have been we have the plan in
place as far as paying off our all of
our debt um you know of course we have
it listed from smallest to largest and
when you were talking about doing that
whole connecting thing I actually am so
I do volunteer work and
um the gal that I do the volunteer work
with as well as she was ahead of the HR
in the old hospital that I just came
from she said hey you know this position
is open and was open with the new
company that I work for now which
happens to be five minutes down the road
and she said I just want to let you know
in case you're interested
um so I did apply for that position I
did send my resume last night so it
would be Staffing for assisted living
Place facility here in in our rural
Northwest Ohio town where we live so I
am already kind of on that Lookout
keeping my eyes and ears open
um but living in very rural Northwest
Ohio we are very limited options so
that's why I said I've doubled my income
going to this company because the pay
around here just isn't well let me say
this I want to drive an hour to the city
and let me encourage you on something
one of the things you may need to look
at is what is the freelance market look
like a lot of freelancing work that's
done remotely because of the freelance
nature I'd be looking at that to
supplement the income a little bit of
overtime George through some freelancing
is somewhere I would start digging
absolutely and that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books appreciate
my co-host Ken Coleman all the guys in
the booth and you America thanks so much
for listening we're going to be back
before you know it
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell joined by my
colleague Ken Coleman this hour and the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're here to
help you to take your calls to help you
with that next step in your financial
Journey your journey through work and
career and purpose you name it let's get
to the phone lines Maggie joins us up
first in Chicago Maggie welcome to the
show
Hi how are you guys we're doing great
how can we help
um so we are about 45 minutes west of
Chicago so we're in the suburbs and it's
really nice here I've lived here my
whole life
um but Illinois is not really going in
the direction that we want it to
um so we are thinking that potentially
after our kids go off to college we
would be moving out of state
um my son my oldest son is 14 my younger
one is nine so about nine more years
until the last one leaves we have eight
more years about to pay off the house
with what we've been doing now
um and so I'm just kind of wondering if
that would still be a good idea to
continue to pay off the house if we kind
of see an end in site where we might be
moving
um and if there's something we should do
with that money instead
well if I'm in your shoes and that's how
we answer calls on this show I am
putting that all towards the house and
my goal would be to have that thing paid
off before we move because what what it
really becomes is a force Savings Plan
okay and if we do other things with that
money it kind of gets a little squishy
and it could disappear we could invest
it and lose some of that and so I love
having this goal of man what if we could
be kind of empty nesters with no
mortgage payment and then if we want to
move what if we could pay cash for that
next house because we don't have a
mortgage so all of that Equity isn't
disappearing it's staying in your house
when you go to sell it and I I want to
ask a a question on this
um
are you staying because you don't want
to uproot the kids because you clearly
don't want to be in Illinois I thought
you really suppressed your real feelings
pretty well and you don't want to put
you on a decade no no you know we we
love our town I grew up here my husband
was from not too far away my parents
live here
um we love it but
um we started seeing I I don't want to
say it's it's a lot of crime but we're
starting to see some some you know like
car and fests and stuff from the city or
from Rockford these kind of groups of
people will come out release people into
neighborhoods get what they can and then
go back so you know again in no way are
we in a bad town at all it's actually
you know a pretty affluent town but you
know the way that Illinois is dealing
with crime and things there's not really
any penalties for things
um so you know just maybe being a little
jumping the gun a little bit on you know
what's good what this is going to look
like in eight to ten years
um you know maybe maybe you know my
nightmares are not actually going to
come true but you know just thinking
long term I we didn't know if it would
be better to kind of pile up that cash
um not knowing if you know where we owe
about 177 on the house now it's probably
worth just a little under 400.
um so if it would be better to you know
if the market were to go down in that
amount of time and it's not worth as
much you know if we would be better kind
of piling up that cash and just doing
that I I was just curious because I was
going to challenge your thinking but I
think now hearing the way you're
responding I I don't I I agree with
George and and and I want to make sure
you heard what he said when he said four
savings he's absolutely spot on because
you just said well I was wondering if we
just pile up the cash piling up the cash
into your greatest asset which is your
home in a very good area outside of a
major city is not risky that is piling
up cash so I agree with George I would
do that because it doesn't sound like to
me that you're super convicted yet
sounds to me like you're worried and
worried is what leads to some conviction
down the line but right now I would just
say you're worried and I think George's
advice is spot on that's not a risky
move or a silly move in any way are you
guys had a place Maggie to throw extra
on the house do you guys have any debt
do you have an emergency fund
yeah we don't have any debt um we were
in the last two years we had to
refinance so we're like 2.625 now
interest rate um and we had
um actually as my dad was sick at the
time last spring so I was driving them
back and forth to Mayo Clinic a lot and
on one of those times my very old um
Honda Odyssey kind of gave up on me so
we ended up having to get a car a little
bit sooner than we thought we were going
to um so I could keep making those trips
and we decided to pay cash for it and
just pay ourselves back in you know six
to eight months of solid so now that
we're we basically we pay everything
with my husband's income and then I'm a
building substitute teacher um so I
don't really make anything you know like
maybe 18 20 000 a year so how many hours
a week are you doing so or rather how
many hours a month are you subbing
I worked five days a week so it's for
the elementary school that my son's at
so I just go every day and then I do
whatever they need me to do but I don't
get sick days I don't get days that you
know like it's an Institute day today
can I can I encourage and challenge you
you can be making a good bit more money
with your skill set and experience
online with uh with doing online
teaching that world has exploded uh my
wife's got a dear friend back in Atlanta
area who is a full-time High School
teacher but makes really good money
teaching Spanish
um in her particular skill set online
for adults I just think you ought to be
looking at the world of online teaching
and tutoring because you're spending a
lot of time five days a week for very
little return and the reason I'm
challenging you on this is is your
particular skill set and experience the
world has changed dramatically and I
think you could make a good night
well okay and that's fine
all of our VCRs that I used to use right
we're kind of you know I was home for 13
years so I'm kind of like all right you
know I'm turning back into it but and
you know I totally agree with what
you're saying here's my if we pay off
that house faster we pay off the house
faster if you dabble in that a little
bit but again you got to make the call I
just wanted to challenge you because it
speeds everything up especially thinking
about it for the summer
um doing something like that or at least
you know what is your household income
with with you bringing in the extra 20
000 What's the total household income
now
I'm probably like 120 I think my
husband's right around 100 he's salary
but he can get some overtime so he does
that from time to time
um and then like I said but we've kind
of since we got married it's always we
want to live on one income and then
whatever it's the extra is either you
know towards a house or vacation or
whatever his his income you know he's
fully funding the
um his yeah obviously the insurance in
the 401K and all that yeah you guys are
investing 15 are you putting some money
away for the kids college
yeah well
we'll end a hundred thousand thousand
per kid awesome you guys are doing so
great I'm proud of you that's fantastic
and I would set a goal with your husband
kind of
yeah he's he's more on the page of my
parents are divorced my mom was on the
side of Pastor house as soon as possible
she did so when my my stepdad who we
were taking back and forth he actually
passed away this fall so you know she's
feeling like it was good that they got
the house paid off and all that my dad
on the other side is where he's like you
have a really low interest and he kind
of has my husband I'm taking Mom's
wisdom on this one Maggie no one has
called in the show saying I regret
paying off my house I hate having all
this extra money what do I do it's a
great feeling psychologically and it's
going to set you guys up financially so
we're rooting for you on whatever's next
thank you so much for the call this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today 8 and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour the number to call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right folks a lot of you have
questions about taxes and we get it
taxes are confusing so to help you get a
better handle on them let's unpack a
question from one of our listeners
here's what they asked I want to avoid
overpaying taxes each month what do I
need to change with my paycheck this is
a great question because Ken you're all
about helping people make more money and
this is one of the easiest life hacks to
make more money you've been given the
government an interest-free loan let's
stop that and so here's what we do we
want to make that money work for you
instead of Uncle Sam and waiting to get
your money back in the form of a tax
refund so there's two simple ways to
figure this out number one if nothing
has changed in your tax situation take
your refund amount or the amount you
owed last year and divide it by 12.
that's how much more or less you want
taken out of your paycheck each month so
for round numbers Ken let's say you got
a 1200 refund well that means you were
overpaying by a hundred bucks every
single month for an entire year
so if your tax situation has changed you
can use tax software to do a fake tax
return to kind of crunch the numbers
here and that will show you if you're
paying too much or too little and you
can do that quick paycheck math again to
figure out that Goldilocks spot and the
next step is to then get with your HR
team with your employer and fill out a
new W-4 that is the form you want to
change to make sure you're not over or
underpaying on your taxes anymore so if
you want more tax tips and software that
can help you file with confidence go to
ramsaysolutions.com smart tax that's
Ramsey smart tax that's uh it'll guide
you through our e-filing with low
upfront pricing no hidden fees like the
other guys just go to
ramsaysolutions.com smart tax
all right let's go to the phones Dan
joins us up next in Fort Worth Dan
welcome to the show
and just following
is great awesome
and I used a premium and I called got
right through and got answers so that's
awesome to hear we couldn't have asked
for a better plug so thank you for that
well let's see I just retired and so I
got several of those papers for
transferring
money out of my company's IR uh 401K so
I agree with all of that tell us about
uh real quick tell us what you retired
from how long were you working in that
field tell us the details there I've had
one and only one job wow and I worked in
another company name or just no you
don't have to it's up to you I just I'm
just curious I'm happy to say it it's
been a good company uh but I've worked
in the um I'm a software engineer and I
worked for a company that uh builds
aircraft
does it start with a B
how many years were you how many years
were you in the role
uh 37. 37 years how long ago did you
retire
uh I last July all right are you
enjoying it
yes I am very much so how old are you
I am I just turned 60 last month oh 60
years young man I couldn't make it that
was my goal to get to 60 and I couldn't
do it but
well 37 years a heck of a career well
done well well done how can we help
today you're treated me very well and
it's and I'm pretty pretty set
financially but that gets to my question
which is
I'm so used to budgeting based on my
income and using the every dollar app
and not used to spending savings so this
is a big my shift for me uh so I've got
a tension of 5200 a month
uh and then I'm pulling I just now
started pulling from my savings
and so the question is is am I pulling
enough not enough
all right we can live on what I'm what
I'm pulling out but this also gets into
how do you do for
do you still do a thinking fund since
you're it's now spending savings instead
of income and I'm worse we've been so
used when you say savings Dan are you
talking about your nest egg actually
pulling from investment accounts
withdrawing yeah yes okay so not a
general savings account we're talking
about I'm utilizing my nest egg
well how much is in the Nestle okay the
nest egg is 1.4 million awesome
yeah and how much are you pulling out
uh we pulled out we moved out of the
taxable into the non uh out of the the
uh the tax-free pulled out so that I
would get 3 000 a month uh for this year
so basically 2 000 a week which we can
easily live on and do uh
we we've lowered our giving based on our
income and the only major up is our
premiums for medical so we hit 65 and
that's uh 1600 a month
so it comes down to
when she asks like hey I'd like to get
in the refrigerator I'm not used to
saying we're gonna have to wait a month
or two
because we used to have a cash flow and
now that I get to decide my own cash
flow I don't know how to decide
and do I leave the big amount in the
nest egg and only pull out like if I
needed a new car which I don't plan on
when that happens or do I start taking
out of what I'm pulling out monthly and
let it build in this little thinking
fund
I think you take what you need at the
time that you need it and so you have
your pension money that's coming in
that's 5200 you said yeah it's very it's
wonderful yeah so that's great so how
much do you need on top of that to cover
your monthly expenses because I assume
and hope you guys are doing a monthly
budget where you're saying here's our
expenses for the month including the
luxuries you guys should be enjoying
this money now
it's more
uh pull more to travel more
yes which
I just got hit it's like oh the
house insurance went up and I hadn't
allocated enough and I could but I'm
used to just being able oh it's
I had a lot of leeway in my budget every
month so we're adjusting things now
because we don't have the same situation
we did pre-retirement so we have to
adjust to our new lifestyle and what it
entails but you can create a cash flow
from these Investments and so the key is
to look at these numbers and go all
right I have 1.4 million if I withdraw
you know three or four percent a year
that should help that money stay at 1.4
million or more yeah
here's what I'm not sure on George asked
you and I don't think we got an answer
does the 5200 a month cover your your
living expenses
uh well uh it would not
um so how much more how much more do you
need above and beyond that just to cover
the four walls and bills you guys have a
mortgage
no okay we're we're debt-free so what is
the 5200 going towards at this point
because it feels like that would be
enough to cover Bare Bones expenses
well out of the 5200 1 600 goes to uh
medical insurance okay now I have an HSA
that we're using now to spend for the
medical bills
we have a very generous food budget
which says eating out groceries and
and uh so that's a thousand a month
there
um we have our giving
uh it's spread out
it's all in the budget
um I believe you so on top of the 5200
yeah you're saying I need about 3 000 on
top of that
yeah okay
thousands so you're taking out about 36
Grand a year from your nest egg is what
I'm hearing yeah and I'm thinking the
question is should I be taking more more
potentials
so that I think I think you're being
conservative
or what out of the nest egg is where I
can just say we want to take a big trip
and take it out and not do it like I do
every save every month for it yeah
that's totally fine if you want to take
if you want to take 10 000 out you
should not touch
it's exhausting I'm exhausted listen to
you think it through it here's the deal
you want to go on a big trip George is
saying things I'm an engineer I know and
we're trying to set you free set your
budget up the way you want to do it with
the extra 3 000 a month ago above and
beyond the pension and when you want to
go on a big trip to Greece with Mama
pull it out of the retirement fund and
pay for it and save it every month it's
gonna be fine what you need to do is
work with a smart investor Pro and
crunch the numbers because right now
it's all kind of a wish and I think and
I hope the smart investor Pro will show
you how these numbers were on run out
and show you okay if you take four
percent out a year Max your money should
last you to 100 and Beyond and that will
free you to spend with no remorse and
with intentionality my friend so go to
ramseysolutions.com and connect with a
smart investor Pro you're doing great
man enjoy it
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Ken
Coleman the number to call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five before
we get to the phone lines let's get to
our question of the day which comes from
Joe and the official Ken Coleman
community on Facebook I always
appreciate people dropping questions in
there you love the official communities
don't you very I don't like the
unofficial ones that's for sure so
here's what Joe wants to know from Ken
Ken what are your thoughts on a career
that has a schedule of eight to five
Monday through Friday but requires you
to be on call 24 7 365. well you better
love it
I mean you better really love it
because this description here says No
Boundaries now that's just the way a lot
of jobs are and I get it
but if you don't love that work and what
I mean by that is is really enjoy let's
call it 75 of your day
if you don't enjoy it
then what's going to happen is
is that becomes so wearing on you
because you never feel like you can turn
it off but if it is a high level of
enjoyment as you know I call that
passion and if it is in your producing
results that motivate you and you go you
know what
um I'm gonna have to make sure that I'm
taking all of my vacation days
I'm gonna have to make sure that I am
truly recreating myself on my weekends
uh you're going to be very very specific
to take care of you if not uh you will
burn out in a role like that because you
have no boundaries so you better love it
you better care deeply about the results
and you better take care of yourself if
you don't it's not a good idea I agree
and I do wonder if this is a
hypothetical I don't know how many roles
are truly 24 7 365 even if you're a
surgeon on call well actually you might
call for two weeks at a time or
something of course it's fair but you
might be surprised like if you're a
plumber or you're a you know even an
emergency situation in emergency
situations uh I know a lot of HVAC guys
that they're on call and and they could
get a call and depending on how the
business wants to operate and how they
want to serve their customers yeah and
by the way I love those dudes I've had
one of those that show up at eight
o'clock on a July summer night in
Nashville yeah yeah I've had one show up
at 2 A.M after my roof was leaking from
an ice dam yeah so that's the I idea
doesn't mean you're always on but you
are on call and you just have to deal
that and you know what we were talking
about this earlier you know I'm always
trying to help people win in their work
life
and I was telling you that you know I've
realized that not everybody's going to
get what I talk about because not
everybody wants to put in the hustle
they just don't
and I think we have to understand this
that like not everybody is wired for
that kind of an on-call mentality some
people can handle it fine but other
people are stressed out of their mind
and anxious so you got to know yourself
you know above and beyond the other way
yeah that's a good good reminder there
thanks for the question Joe appreciate
all of you in the official Ken Coleman
Community you can find that on Facebook
if you want to jump into that
conversation by the way before we get
back to the phones if you want to make
more money
and you don't feel you're making enough
I'm your guy I'm on call right now right
now he's here and so phone lines are
open so many people feel like they just
aren't making enough and I'm telling you
we are sitting right now in a job
economy what's one of the biggest
complaints Ken they're gonna can the
wages have stagnated how can anyone
survive the prices of eggs yeah and
you're going well you can make more well
wages have not stagnated which is why
everything costs more but saying the
word stagnated makes us feel good well
you like to say it because you like a 10
word yeah all right back to the phones
we go all right we're gonna go to Kyle
in New York City Kyle my friend welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help today
so I have a question so first of all I'm
26 years old and I just have a question
on um term life insurance I don't know
if I should do 10 20 30 years
basically I don't know if I should do a
30 or now just because I'm young and
obviously it's going to be a lot cheaper
but then I'm afraid I'd be hammered with
a crazy price once I'm like 56 or if
it's better to do like a 10 now and then
a 30 later on so then it brings me to
like I'm 66. it's a great question so
are you single
no I actually just got married oh
wonderful congratulations it's exciting
thank you so we we generally recommend
anywhere from 10 to 20 years with term
life insurance and here here's why if
you follow the Ramsey plan and I'm
talking all in not ish here's how this
would play out you would get a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage eventually in the
next few years potentially right yep
once you're debt free with a fully
funded emergency fund and so think about
that if you guys have kids let's say in
the next five years is that a reasonable
assumption if you do want kids
yes definitely and so 20 years from now
25 years from now the kids are out of
the house you have a paid for house and
you've been investing for 25 years
15 of your income and then even beyond
that once you have the house paid off
and so that would cause you to become
what we call self-insured where if
something happened to you God forbid
your wife's gonna be okay
she's got a million dollars in the bank
she's got very little expenses she's
gonna be okay so the point of term life
insurance is not to have it until the
day you die
right
and so that's what I would do get 10 to
12 times your income and as your income
goes up you can increase that some
people get a new policy in place and
cancel the old one sometimes it makes
sense to increase the ones you got some
people do a ladder strategy where they
may you know you've got the 15 year in
place you may 10 years down the road add
another 15 year in place and as long as
you're healthy those rates are going to
be so affordable you're going to be
really grateful anytime I see that life
insurance premium come through which I
pay mine annually to get it get a
discount you know me I love a good deal
oh yeah and instead of going oh man I'm
grateful that it was another year that I
said I love you to my family through the
form of term life oh yeah and this is
and this is before you're you know you
even have kids when kids enter the
equation I gotta tell you
um we have ours automated but I always
get paranoid every year I always say did
it go through you know because I I can't
think of a more
shameful Act
that I could do
than to die without life insurance to
take care of Stacy and the kids
I I just it it is the most financially
responsible unselfish thing that you can
do
um and so uh I love that this question
is here and this is it's a game changer
there's a lot of Peace man it it really
does I mean different people deal with
death differently but I got to tell you
if you know that if something happens to
you that your family is not going to
want for anything that everything's
gonna be okay it's the Final Act of
sacrifice and devotion and I think it's
that serious it really is beautifully
said Kyle does that answer your question
it does so you're basically able to
cancel a life insurance policy whenever
you want yeah and then replace it with
something else that's right okay and I
actually did that recently and I I found
it made more sense just to go ahead and
get a new policy uh you know as your
income goes up over the years which it
will you want to make sure you're
keeping up with that to make sure that
you can cover you know your lifestyle
and your expenses and make sure your
spouse has one too
okay 10 to 12 times there anyway thank
you guys yeah and let me call out that
it for the stay-at-home moms out there
yeah they need term life insurance
that's correct because if something
happens to that stay-at-home spouse you
got to get Mary Poppins to cover all the
thousands of Duties that we're taken
care of and let me tell you that gets
expensive very very quickly that's right
yeah and so stay-at-home parents we
recommend anywhere you know we're
talking 250 000 to 400 000 worth of term
life insurance and sometimes more
depending on your situation your cost of
living if you live in Manhattan you know
Child Care is going to be a lot more
expensive yeah and so be thinking about
that and make sure if anyone relies on
your income get term life insurance
avoid avoid whole life insurance like
the plague it's being peddled right now
Ken on social media on Tick Tock oh yeah
everything's research it's like an
investment scheme you can borrow from
yourself and it's you can become your
own bank don't fall for those traps
please yeah so get term life get it in
place set it and forget it like the
Great Grandpa peel you remember those
commercials yeah oh yeah rotisserie
chicken oh yeah I always think about it
I'm an old man at heart Ken you are and
by the way uh it's also important to
point out that term life rates are so
incredibly low you ought to be checking
in with Xander Insurance some of you
guys that got it maybe 10 years ago
maybe you're out of shape your your
cholesterol level is a little high in
your blood hey it gives you a good
excuse to lose about 10-15 pounds so
watch your rates drop I'm not kidding
you ramsaysolutions.com and you can
click on trusted Services
wow taking care of the family that's who
me and Ken go through we recommend it to
everyone they'll take care of you give
you the best rate shopping across all of
the top rated companies are not beholden
to one company and they are incredible
incredible people so great question love
talking about term life for some reason
camera do you really I'm a giant nerd I
don't know what to tell you need a you
need a more exciting one I need help
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
please
foreign
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Ramsey personality
joined by my friend Ken Coleman this
hour the number to call is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Ken is
here to help you get that breakthrough
with your work your purpose your career
help you make more money if you're
feeling stuck you're facing a layoff
whatever it is he is your man and I can
help you with all those financial
questions to get you on the path to
wealth we're going to take a call from
Rebecca in Guilford New Hampshire
Rebecca how you doing
hi I'm good how are you we're doing
great how can we help great okay so um
I'm lying because I'm ready to start the
baby step number four but I'm
um I may be on if I contribute to my own
Roth IRA my employer's Roth IRA
or here's the loop um start saving for
my future husband's debt
wow payoff is this man in the picture
already
he is okay good I didn't know if it was
a hypothesis
you know okay yeah so are you engaged
yes exciting congratulations when's the
wedding
uh it'll be June 10th of
2024. wonderful okay so you're at baby
step four and until we're married we're
not going to combine finances and so as
long as you are investing 15 and also
able to cash flow the wedding that would
be the plan of attack
okay so let's talk about is the wedding
gonna be paid for by you two
yes
yes okay and you're gonna cash flow it
you've got the budget set you know
you're going to hit that number
100 yes yeah we're gonna
um elope and kind of just do it
budget friendly
yes okay so let's talk about baby step
four we recommend investing 15 of your
household income into retirement so
you're saying you have an employer 401k
correct yes okay and you're saying hey
should I do my own Roth IRA now you you
mentioned an employer Roth IRA I think
you're talking about the 401K because
the IRA is outside of your employer
okay yes okay yes so here's a real
simple investing strategy and it's the
one that Dave uses and our whole team
uses the one that we recommend to
millions of people and it's real simple
it goes match beats Roth beats
traditional so do you have an employer
match
yes I do awesome okay what's the match
oh I think
I'm not exactly sure
um
but it's a few percent is it just kind
of a three or four percent five percent
yes you
let's pretend it's three percent so the
first three percent of the 15 we're
gonna put towards that match
now you said you have a Roth 401k option
through your employer
yes and so Roth would come next and if
you have good investment options with
that 401k you could do all 15 into that
401k
okay
and if you don't have good investment
options or if someone didn't have a Roth
option for the 401K it was traditional
you would go to the Roth IRA outside of
your employer and put as much in as
there as you can there I think it's 6
500 for this year and if you still
haven't hit 15 of your income you go
back to the 401K
okay so it sounds like you could do all
15 what's your household income
mine I only I make
okay
who's Rebecca and you've got good
investment options I'm just going to do
all 15 into that Roth 401k and that will
get you the match and that'll get you to
uh your baby step four limit
yeah way to go excited for the marriage
I love the idea of a loping cat I think
we need to get back to that I I've said
this many times before uh speaking on
behalf of all men uh men if you're if
you're a wife to be is in favor of this
jump on this opportunity because it's a
lot of stress on women because it's a
big day and I will tell you he's a guy
you could when the ceremony is over you
think to yourself why do we go through
six months or ten months or 12 months of
planning for what amounts to about a 20
25 minute ceremony
and then the party and then we leave on
the honeymoon so I think most guys would
just rather do without the ceremony I
had an idea I'm gonna run it by you what
do you think about we just treat
weddings like a live event that you buy
tickets to
so you want to attend the Ken and Stacy
wedding you're paying you buy a ticket
yeah and that just covers the wedding
price and we're good I think it's a
horrible idea I don't think anybody who
does it no one does that well it covers
the cost of the wedding now we're not
going hey Ken and Stacy have to front
you presume it covers the cost of the
wedding that people would pay to come
see you get married well it takes the
place of the gift
I see but to see I don't think it works
that way I think Americans have too much
consumer guilt and they they would bring
a blender and then they got to buy a
ticket and what's the ticket price by
the way I don't know it depends on the
wedding I'd pay 50 bucks includes a meal
and if you know you would pay 50 bucks
to see me and Stacy get married you know
how much it costs for a seat at a
wedding
for a ceremony and reception I didn't
ask you that I asked you what you would
pay to watch someone else get married
depends if I like them like our producer
James I'd throw in 50 bucks for James I
promise you right now James wouldn't pay
to come to either one of our weddings it
depends on if there's a live camel there
I did have a live camel at my wedding so
there's a perk the only way James Childs
our fearless producer pays to come to
one of our weddings is if it includes a
uh all you can eat buffet then he's in
outside of that he's not paying and if
he can bring his kids too or if you and
Stacy wear matching plaid outfits not
that that would ever happen too soon
that's an inside inside basement very
good inside joke by the way it was not
plaid it was Tartan let's get it
straight you just made it worse somehow
no no it's Christmas Tartan all right
look it up let's go to Sean Sean please
save us he's in Phoenix how you doing
hey good guys how you doing good what's
your question
so the question is is uh back in October
I uh purchased a vehicle uh a Tesla to
save on gas because I might worry work
uh truck I was spending almost fourteen
hundred dollars a month in gas uh gas
price got pretty expensive here so I was
looking to save so purchase that I
didn't have even the money exactly then
I pulled money from my e-lock to make
that purchase uh November December are
normally our better months I'd almost do
about a third of my income just in those
two months well those months didn't pan
out uh there's been like a downturn
going on so I've had a drastic kind of
cutting income and question is now is
like should I sell stocks to pay it off
because like I'm worried about interest
rates going up still here again
I don't know
yes yes so like when I initially when I
initially had it it was like when I did
it I think it was at like five percent
or so now it's like at nine and I'm
anticipating that maybe raising rates
again what do you owe on here
48 and how much do you have in stocks
like in one investment account around 40
47 uh there in another I got 30. like I
have enough to liquidate them there on
those those are just my kind of
individual investment accounts not like
IRAs or so we're not touching retirement
these are just taxable investment
accounts and you have single stocks in
there
uh so I own three houses one is my
primary residence and then two are
rentals one of the rentals is paid off
the other one's not uh that one I owe so
between I guess my personal residence I
owe uh 479 on
and then on the other rental I owe one
or 169. okay I have no other Consumer
Debt
just the two mortgages okay and what's
your household income borrowing you know
your terrible months that you had
see normally I'd be running around like
360 to 390 in this last uh close closed
out at like 2 40. so there's been like a
drastic
drop that I had and like I said I was
just really banking on November December
I'm like oh well this is kind of Make It
or Break It there and I was really kind
of making it just yeah didn't really pan
out so but this was kind of my backup
plan and now or well that's that's the
thing you know our plan works in good
times and bad and this is one of those
ones where it gets scary when you have
volatile stocks sitting out there and so
if I'm in your shoes I'm cashing out on
all of the stocks I'm clearing the HELOC
having a big pile of cash fry emergency
fund and starting to tackle those
mortgages and I know you said the stocks
are making money but they make money
until they don't make money and then
you're down 20 in a market but when you
don't have any debt it just changes the
numbers and changes your decisions so I
cash out of that make sure you
understand the tax implications on the
gains of course and you pay those but uh
we're rooting for you to become debt
free my man thanks for the call that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to my co-host Ken
Coleman all the folks in the booth
keeping the show float and you America
thanks for listening we'll be back real
soon
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to ramsesolutions.com
today to sign up for the newsletter
again that's ramsesolutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by my good
friend Ken Coleman and we want you to
jump in with your question this is your
show we want to help you take the right
next step in your life the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five Zechariah kicks us off in
Branson Zechariah welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you guys for accepting my call
happy to accept how can we help you
today
uh definitely so my question currently
is
um by the way again I am 18 years old I
graduated high school when I was 17 and
I'm about to actually graduate in May to
get my associates in business
um as far as my question goes I've
inherited the house uh in in May I did
and um it was my father's
I'm not sure if I should continue
evolving my career in Branson or to go
and pursue education to a higher degree
um like at a university of some sort and
then sell the house so my kind of
question for you guys would be should I
continue to pursue education and kind of
Lee Branson as there's not much here
career-wise for me in sales or in
business or should I go ahead and um
stay here
well I think that's depending on what it
is you want to do long term and you're a
really bright young man who's already
made some progress it sounds like
you see yourself long term outside of
Branson so that's one indicator but
before we decide on more education and
I'm super passionate about this
Zechariah because the the world has told
you
and and many other people for decades
that a degree is a guarantee for success
and that's a bunch of garbage even more
so now in 2023 and so I don't want to go
for more education unless it is the only
way
to do what I want to do or it's the best
way so it's a very simple uh decision
process is it the only way to get where
I want to go professionally or is it the
best way and parents this is for you too
there's this cultural pressure for you
to send your kid to college because it's
about status now it's a status symbol
it's no guarantee for Success so the
question for you as young man like do
you know what you want to do long term
yeah which is why my my school had a
program I spent like three years in it
because I SMS aim I I asked myself the
same question great um so I've partnered
up with a few local physician assistants
and I've shadowed them for the past two
to three years and
um I honestly think it's kind of a queer
for me it is great he had a master's
degree though fantastic I mean okay so
that answers our question all right so
is it the only way the answer is yes all
right so now we have to decide
do I need to go to a name brand School
the answer that is no
and so once I decide okay what are my
options what are the financial
requirements for me to get through that
program that Masters
and that's going to decide our timeline
we want you to save up the money to be
able to cash flow your way through the
master's program okay you don't have to
move outside of Branson necessarily
to do that you might want to but let's
just go to the best opportunity to get
trained that doesn't cost as much money
nobody cares I've never ever ever George
gone to the doctor and before I was
examined I didn't say could you tell me
where you went to school and also what
your GPA was nobody ever does that
so let's get over all this name brand
crap and this pressure like well I would
to this school nobody freaking cares all
right so once we decide where we want to
go to school
and then uh we figure out how much money
it's going to take
then the rest of these decisions take
care of themselves right so now if you
say in Branson in the house you
inherited because you can go to school
locally fantastic right but if you need
to move uh because of the schooling and
you don't have the money saved up then
it's going to take us a little bit of
time to stay in my sales job and save up
the money and then I'm gonna make the
move so I I think all of your big
decisions have already been made it's
now just a selection what mountain
do I want to climb as it relates to the
school what's the best place for me to
go and then we make the decisions from
there does that make sense
yeah yeah definitely I I think it's more
so kind of the paralysis by analysis
yeah of uh looking at looking at a huge
huge kind of question or thing that you
should do do you I mean do you guys
believe like if I did went ahead and
decided to go to college just like an
hour away from here
um and in that event did want to sell
the home as far as like taking that and
uh investing obviously in the market and
you know not even touching it just
letting it cash flow to me
um do you guys think it would be
better to kind of pursue that or do you
guys think it would just be how much
what's the house worth
uh the house right now is worth 282.
okay so let's call it you know maybe 250
is what you would net how much do you
have in the bank right now
uh currently having the bank around 15.
okay and let's call that your emergency
fund do you have any debt
I do not so let's figure out what it's
going to take to cash flow this master's
degree because we may need some of those
funds let's say we do sell it that could
help you cash flow the Masters yep
do you know what that might cost you
um
uh yeah it's oh it's a Mrs MSU up here
in Springfield
um total I think for undergraduate uh
plus Masters they both cost the same
thankfully so it's easy math um I think
it was around 15 per year okay so is
that total uneven yeah is that a total
six years
four or five years how many years
no that that's just for one year no no I
know but how many years before you get
through the Masters is a is it a
four-year or is your associate you got
some credits transferring so how many
years before you get out of the master's
program and can actually be a PA
it would be five all right okay so
there's your number so now we have real
hard numbers there's no longer a kind of
you know wishy-washy thing going on here
so 75 grand is what it's going to take
so if you sell this house you net 250
I'm gonna put that in a high yield
savings account I would not invest it
into the market because that 250 could
turn into 200 depending on how things go
and who tweeted what that day so I'd
rather have that money liquid cash it'll
grow at you know three or four percent
with uh today's high yield savings rates
and that will really float you through
this in a beautiful way and also you're
gonna need to rent are you going to be
able to work while you're in school
uh yeah I um I I might see plus plus on
my python programmer certification so
that's what I do now what can't you do
I I suck at drawing so I mean it makes
me feel better I love that he actually
took the question seriously he was like
well uh I'm having a hard time thinking
of something I can't do no listen uh
Zechariah you're in great shape my
friend and George's advice is right
you're gonna have a lot of people try to
give you some opposite advice to that
but you want that cash so that when you
get done with the Masters and you're
ready to take that job and be a PA now
you've got a pretty sizable down payment
uh you got a lot of options my friends
we don't know we're gonna end up long
term so I don't want you to get you know
go buy a place not knowing what's next
because someone told you it's a waste to
rent I don't think that at all I think
you're gonna do so well at 18 to be this
sharp just call us back when you're a
millionaire like four years from now
this kid's brilliant yeah cheering you
on man this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show if
you're listening to this show I'm going
to make a wild assumption that you enjoy
it and if you enjoy it I'd like to
remind you that it's free and therefore
I have one ask of you and that is to
consider subscribing to the show
wherever you're listening leaving us a
review wherever you're listening and
sharing it with a friend send them a
link telling tell them about it send
them to our site we want to spread hope
as much as we can this year and if
you've read the headlines there's not a
lot of it out there and so we try to be
a beacon of light in in this world
that's gone mad apparently so we
appreciate all of our listeners out
there keep spreading the word we love
you guys let's go to the phones Roslyn
joins us in Tyler Texas Roslyn welcome
to the show
hi hey how are you taking my call sure
good
so I have a question about I suppose
investing I am wondering if it would be
wise for me to put money into a CD
accounts okay what's this money for
this would be
okay what are your current financial
goals kind of give us a picture of where
you're at do you have any debt do you
have money in the bank
account and I have no debt I'm a
university student student going on
scholarship wonderful full ride
yes sir way to go and how much longer do
you have to until you graduate
year and a half to two years
awesome how'd you get the full ride
uh well I
applied to the University of Tyler at or
University of Texas at Tyler and they
have a fantastic nursing program so
you've got a full ride for nursing
yes sir way to go you're incredible I
wish Christine Alice was here she would
be hooting and hollering for you right
now but you got me in Kent so we you
know we're not as good at that but
here's what to do with that money you
mentioned a CD a certificate of deposit
and I'm not a fan of CDs and it's for a
simple reason you are locking up your
money at a fixed interest rate
and so what I'd rather see you do with
that money is put it into a online
high-yield savings account which is a
variable interest rate which means you
can make more money over time versus
getting stuck with whatever the CD is
paying you and if you need that money
anytime you can use it without any
penalties or fees
okay and so I would avoid that there's
lots of options out there we don't have
any you know Partners or advertisers in
the space but I know Ally and Marcus are
a great options for you to look into for
that online savings account and you can
get upwards of you know four percent
more just in that high yield savings
account and it'll stay completely liquid
you'll be able to transfer it to your
checking account at any time in case you
need it which you know as a college
student we just don't know what the next
few years hold as far as what your
expenses will be well if you'll have a
car repair and so I don't want that
money locked up in a CD to where if you
pull it out you're gonna have a penalty
or fee
okay that makes sense yeah well thank
you so much for the question and the
call very sharp we're getting I'm seeing
a theme Here Ken of really smart young
people yeah you know this idea by the
way where we generalize around
Generations you know as if to say that
there's only certain generations with
you know Eagles in it and everybody else
is a donkey it's just silly I mean every
generation's got their Duds and their
Stars we tend to get the Stars on this
show we appreciate it I think that's
true all right let's go to June over in
Phoenix June welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call absolutely
I have a question
um I've been with my company for 15
years
I've been able to
learn a ton of things I love working
there great people
but there's been a company that's been
reaching out to me and we're getting
pretty close to an offer right now
and I'm I don't know how mentally to
transfer outside of my company
meaning is it worth it like is it ever
worth it to even like is there do I put
a dollar amount on it or is over time
not to to leave a company well sure but
but you're you're wrestling with really
the same question you're kind of asking
it two different ways so you never want
to leave for just a paycheck because a
lot of people did that over the last two
two and a half years and now they call
it the great regret or people chased a
bigger paycheck and then they were it's
not necessarily they were lied to in
some cases they were but other cases it
just was sold it seemed like the grass
was going to be greener yeah and they
get there right so you have to make a
total decision so pay is a part of it
but it really needs to be purpose and
what I mean by that is is this a job
that either puts you squarely where you
want to be it's the work that you're
really good at you really enjoy it and
it creates results that naturally
motivate you that's what I call the
sweet spot right now that's that is that
is a dream job a lot of people think the
word the phrase dream job is like this
Fantastical Unicorn it's actually not it
feels like a dream because think about
that if you're spending most of your day
using what you do best doing something
you love and caring deeply about the
result that you're creating that feels
really fantastic
and that's that is just a wonderful
place to be and so it feels like a dream
now you want to go to a company where
you're doing work that you absolutely
feel equipped to do
that you are going to enjoy doing or at
least it's putting you on the next rung
of the ladder
so that you can get to ultimately where
you want to go so it's either the right
seat of the bus because it's ultimately
where you want to be or it's the seat
you got to be in to get where you
ultimately want to go then the pay's got
to make sense
and then the third piece is the culture
needs to be healthy because you could
actually get the first two right it
could be the right seat on the bus and
the right pay but it's a horrible bus to
be on and you're not going to want to
stay on that bus very long so those are
the three elements the actual purposeful
work is the first and most important pay
and then culture this makes sense and
then if all three of those check the box
then you need to feel okay leaving and
the way you pose that question I wonder
if you've got a little bit of
unnecessary guilt about the idea of even
leaving
so is that how long have you been there
15 years wow so this is this is very
emotional it's like a breakup it is so
June listen I get this call all the time
on the Ken Coleman Show Ken how do I
deal with the guilt of leaving a company
that's been good to me it's very simple
yeah
if you leave June for a much better
opportunity for you
is that illegal yes or no
no is it unethical yes or no
no all right so actually
this idea of guilt
is really you dealing with fear of what
people will say about you if you leave
them
okay because when you start to when you
start to manifest that what are they
going to say how are they going to feel
when I walk in and turn to my
resignation George Well it feels like a
betrayal to you yes as a person leaving
yeah yeah so you start to assume that
they're all going to be mad at you and
say evil things about you and whatever
whatever and before you know it you go
oh that means that would be a bad thing
to do if they say bad things about me
and so now I feel guilty so it all
starts with fear so I've I ran you
through those questions for you to
realize that you're not doing anything
wrong at all and you cannot control how
they act and what they say you cannot
control that
that's correct okay the other piece is
just the discomfort of change you've
been you've gotten real comfortable with
where you've been for 15 years
here's what coffee maker is here's where
the bathrooms are yeah this is my
favorite stall you know these are the
kinds of things you kind of get used to
and so there's going to be some change
which is uncomfortable but it's also
exciting so I really lean into the
excitement of it and here's the thing
June if you don't let's say that this
job that they're offering you checks out
on all three of those boxes that I gave
you just a moment ago if I think it is
that's the scary part well okay so
George brings up a very good point about
the comfort factor but if you don't take
this gig
for the two reasons we just pointed out
it's change which means it's
uncomfortable
right or
it's the whole I'm afraid whatever
you're going to say about me and so it's
a skill guess what's going to happen
you're gonna end up presenting those
people and you're gonna end up being
miserable so you get to choose do you
want to stay and resent and be miserable
or do you want to move forward and step
into that uncomfort and on the other
side of that
a better life that's the choice yeah I
don't want to live with that kind of
regret I'd rather leave with a little
bit of discomfort instead absolutely
well we're cheering you on June happy
for you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm George camel joined by Ken
Coleman this hour
Sarah joins us up next in Illinois Sarah
welcome to the Ramsey show how you doing
I'm good thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help today
okay so I'm on baby step two and I'm
trying to figure out what the student
loans on hold
um I'm trying to figure out if I should
be setting setting up an income-based
repayment plan
just so that I can actually afford to
live
what is your income
so I'm a teacher I'm a single mom I make
about 43 000 a year okay and how much do
you have in student loans
um student loans I have a hundred and
thirteen thousand
and do you have any other debt
uh the only other debt that I have left
is just a car payment which I only have
6 000 left on that awesome I've paid off
about twelve thousand dollars so far way
to go proud of you so how much longer to
get this car loan out of your life
well my goal is to have it gone by
beginning of June
that's a good goal and are these student
loans broken up into a bunch of little
student loans
I just have two loans left okay so
there's two giant loans that make up the
under 13.
yes okay and are they Federal
yes okay
so what is the minimum payment on those
loans once they get unpaused
uh 1 322.60
okay and what is your take-home pay
every month
about twenty four hundred dollars okay
so the majority of your paycheck is
going towards these student loans and
you still got to pay rent and feed the
kid and you know keep the lights on
right um
I'm so sorry
My worry is is that like I've been
busting my butt clearly
um
working extra jobs any extra money sorry
oh my gosh it's okay um take your time
you're fine you're incredible
I just worry about those months that
like I just lost my second job I was
waitressing so I'm trying to find
another one and so My worry is if it's
that big of a payment
I want to get this done
but what if I don't have that money that
month
this is would it be smart to do
the lower cost and then just try to
throw every little extra bit that I have
at it knowing that I can at least make
that minimum
and then hopefully
you know make it my goal to make it that
1300 every month I totally understand
and I know that it feels like you don't
have options right now but I will say
that the income-based repayment plan is
one of the worst options out there and
it's actually hurting people like you
the most and it makes me really angry
because here's what those income-based
repayment plans do they cause you to
stay in debt for the rest of your life
and the balance will grow because you're
not even touching the principle
great and so it's not actually a
solution even though they pitch it as
one yeah so there is one solution that
you can look into which is student loan
refinancing
and here is when it makes sense to do
student loan refinancing it's got to be
free to make the change so no
application fees no origination charges
and you've got to keep the fixed rate if
you have one of these all fixed rate
loans
yes okay good so we want to make sure we
stay with a fixed rate if we do the
refinancing and then we also want to
make sure it doesn't extend the terms
so if you're on a 10-year we don't want
to make it a 15. that's how car dealers
get you to have lower payments is they
keep you in debt longer and then lastly
it's got to lower the interest rate for
it to make sense because that's going to
lower your payment as well and help you
actually attack this debt
okay and so you can look into that as an
option to see if refinancing that would
help get those payments lower but at the
end of the day we've got to get your
income up in order to tackle this debt
it's not going to go away you can't
bankrupt student loans it's one of the
worst types out there and and if you
want to go watch borrowed future to get
riled up about this we go in depth on
this issue as well so I want to dive in
and let's see if we can come up with
some income opportunities here because
part of the emotion that you're facing
is you're just physically and mentally
exhausted and so what we want to try to
do is give you the best opportunity to
make the most amount of money and I want
to walk through that so what are you
making as a teacher
uh forty three thousand okay and then
you said you had two other jobs you lost
one waitressing job what was the other
one making for you
um I'm doing redoing furniture
okay
um I'm finding furniture on the side and
I'm painting it and selling it how's
that and what kind of money are you
making on a monthly basis with that
so in the last month I made a thousand
okay and then how much money were you
making waitressing
um waitressing I was making about 800 a
month all right okay and uh so here's my
point I I want you right now because you
have to you've got to say wait a second
I've got a finite amount of time
and I'm so proud of you and you're
busting it but I would rather you be
finding a better alternative to the time
you're spending on buying and then
repainting Furniture that's time and
right now we want to do two things with
our time okay we want to make sure that
we aren't wasting any of it just with
trying to find some every second that
we're working we have to be making money
not Prospect or anything else and so we
want to maximize that too by having the
best pain gig when we're doing the extra
work okay so that's your mindset because
what that will do is not only just bring
in more money but it's also going to
give you a bump emotionally to go oh I'm
actually making more with the time I'm
spending so I'm thinking maybe a better
waitressing job right where you're
actually making more in tips maybe a
better situation that's just one idea
but I want you getting creative and
everybody that you know in your area
you're going look here's my situation
single mama I'm a school teacher
and I got this debt I need I've got x
amount of hours I'm just I'm making this
up for for the mindset piece I've got 20
hours extra I got 20 hours I need to be
making
15 20 an hour I mean let's put it out
there
and let's go after that because all of a
sudden you're going to get a little bit
more momentum and you start to make more
progress because you can do this I know
you're tired but you can do this but
you've got to be more efficient with
your time so that you're making more
money don't just take a job let's get
the best paying job possible okay so
that you're making more money and then
you're making more progress do you
understand what I'm saying
yes yeah and Sarah I want to help equip
you to make the most of every one of
those dollars coming in so we're going
to gift you one year of every dollar
premium as well as Financial Peace
University I want you to watch all the
lessons start doing that budget because
you will actually feel so much peace I
know it feels like there's not a lot
left at the end of the month but when
you do this budget and you go okay
here's my money coming in here's every
dollar going out I've given it a job
it's going to go towards the debt it's
going to go towards the the rent
whatever it is you're going to feel such
peace and in control of your situation
and it's going to show you hey if I had
an extra 500 bucks coming in here's how
that would change the numbers on this so
it's going to really encourage you and
I'm also going to make sure Austin gets
you a link to our page that will make
sure that you can refinance your student
loans the right way
there's so many traps out there and
terrible debt consolidation companies
and so we want to steer you in the right
direction when it comes to this
refinancing and a real quick question
here I'm still brainstorming Sarah uh
what are you Elementary School teaching
what's your expertise what subject
matter what what kind of skill set
experience do you have as a teacher
music okay okay
I want you to research online teaching
opportunities within music okay
because you're we're seeing things as
low as 16 an hour to twenty eight
dollars an hour and in some premium
situations you can make fifty to seventy
five dollars an hour that's a game
changer is it not
yeah huge
well let's start looking hey don't you
ever count out a single mama
and I'm telling you right now you you
can find where there's a will there's a
way I'm looking for some opportunities
maybe where I'm not schlepping tables
and you're at home
that's a whole lot better environment so
I want you looking for online tutoring
and teaching situations within your
expertise let's at least give it a shot
absolutely Sarah hang on the line we're
gonna get you all of those resources you
are a hero we want to encourage you and
tell you that you are going to get
through this and I can't wait to
celebrate your debt free scream uh more
than almost anyone else because you are
doing such a hard thing but such a
worthy thing to change your family tree
and get out of this mess thank you for
the call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day comes from Romans 8
28 and we know that for those who love
God all things work together for good
for those who are called according to
his purpose
the great Fred Rogers once said often
out of periods of losing come the
greatest strivings toward a new winning
streak
that's good stuff you know I should if
I'd have known we were having a Mr
Rogers quote today I would have wore a
car again you do love a good cardigan I
love a good cardigan in all their forms
missed opportunity it's all right well
hey we are having a good time on the
spring Building Wealth live time oh man
it's been fun it's already halfway over
Ken yeah you were you were in
Indianapolis uh I was in Austin we've
got what uh Salt Lake coming up and then
Anaheim and then Anaheim to round it out
oh wow so uh the first half of the tour
completely sold out packed house it's
been amazing next up like Ken mentioned
we've got Salt Lake City then Anaheim
and uh we're coming your way so if you
want to join us you can do that April
24th Salt Lake City Dave Ramsey Rachel
Cruz Christina Ellis and myself and then
Anaheim with Dave Ramsey Ken Coleman Dr
John deloney and Christina Ellis on May
5th they can't pair Ken and I together
on these events it's just it's too much
powerful too much for the crowd they
don't really can't handle it yeah it's
this is tough it's like it's like seeing
a Beatles concert
lose their minds right who do you yell
for you can't it's yeah so that's why
they split it at least that's what it is
in our head so if you want to join us
grab your ticket now before they're all
gone tickets start at just 49 bucks you
can go to ramsaysolutions.com
events today and uh this weekend Ken you
know what I'll be doing some light
reading because the Ramsey newsletter is
dropping on Sunday and we've got the 10
best apps that make you money and that's
speaking my language
you know I'm I'm all about saving money
I love making money and I love apps did
you make this list uh you know I'm not
sure I'll have to go check you're so
busy you can't remember well I've done
I've done a lot of articles on our site
about that I'm not sure this particular
one is from me or from our team I'll
tell you my favorite all-time George
Campbell app hack or whatever you want
to call it yeah what do you got you you
told me how to go into Southwest
Airlines app and re-book your flight and
save money and uh he did it one time at
dinner
uh blew my mind saved you hundreds of
bucks right hundreds of dollars just
like that that's why that's why I follow
George Campbell I appreciate that Ken
well you can follow me and you can also
check out that Ramsey newsletter it's
free to sign up ramsayslutions.com
newsletter and this is not going to be
another thing in your inbox we want to
help you win with money making more
saving more be sure to check that out
all right let's get to the phones Megan
is waiting in Fort Worth Megan welcome
to the show
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call I really appreciate it oh
absolutely how can we help
hey so um first I'm crying I'm a little
nervous um you're doing great thanks
guys so um my husband uh and I are um
just kind of starting our journey
um basically the back story is um he
finished residency a year ago and for
the first three years of our marriage
when he was in residency I just kind of
dealt with the fact that we had a ton of
student loan debt
um and then I was listening to your show
a couple weeks ago and I heard Dr deloni
talk about having the I can't breathe
talk with your spouse so that advice was
so helpful because I actually I wrote it
out and I shared with my husband like
this the student loan is killing my
piece and I can't breathe and since then
it's been a really good discussion
between my husband and I but
um he's more on the sense of we have a
really low interest rate he'd rather pay
our loan off a little slower but he is
willing to work with me on the debt
payoff if we want to be intense about it
um we have two small kids I left my job
to stay home with them when we were in
residency I do work some side hustles on
the on the side to bring in some extra
income but my I have two questions one
is could you just give me a pat on the
back to what to affirm me that paying
off our debt is actually the right call
and my second question is do I need to
be bringing in more money
um because I feel like of the two of us
I have the smaller shuttle
um I guess that's because we're having
our first budget meeting tonight to
really hash out the numbers here and I'm
a little intimidated
um about about sticking with my gut on
this and just paying off the debt does
that make sense yeah but George is going
to tell you how to how to play this out
but this is bigger than your gut this is
proven over decades and decades and
Decades of people following these baby
steps so I want you to set yourself free
and trying to sell your husband on this
that this isn't a gut feeling this is a
proven fact George it's not disputable
that the baby steps work yeah well and
he's he's there crunching the numbers
you know he's a smart guy and he's going
well well honey it's a slow interest
rate I don't see the rush in paying this
off but what you see is not numbers what
you're feeling is the emotion and he
can't get there right now and so I think
this is a continued discussion and math
is part of it if you show him on paper
hey what if we got aggressive what would
it look like if we paid this off
aggressively this was our one Focus for
the next few years to get rid of this
debt how could that set us up for the
future and remind him I stayed home to
to be with our kids it's a sacrifice
financially it's a sacrifice in a whole
bunch of ways and the only way I'm going
to feel good about this is if we don't
have any debt and we have that peace and
we have that margin and we have those
options and so doing a budget is a great
step I'm glad that he's actually willing
to take a step into this I think it
needs to go a step further uh have you
guys been through Financial Peace
University together
no we haven't no okay well I'm gonna
give up that'll help I'll gift it to you
so there's no financial burden on you
guys any further than these student
loans have caused and here's here's what
I'm asking and you need to ask him will
you watch all nine lessons with me and
have the discussions and actually be
open-minded and take it seriously
I would love that and if he's willing to
do that we're also going to gift you
guys every dollar premium which is going
to make your budget meeting tonight a
whole lot better because this will
connect to your bank you'll have the
transactions you'll have paycheck
planning and it's going to give you guys
some real peace and control and
hopefully it also shows him all the
money leaks because you guys have
probably been living pretty good pretty
comfortably up until this point
yeah for the first year we've just been
settling into our new
um life and then also I woke up and was
like wait a minute what are we doing
here we need to have a plan absolutely
sure and you're going to get that piece
so the pat on the back is there you're
doing the right thing getting this debt
out of your life and I haven't had
anyone call us back and go hey I paid
off my student loans aggressively and
now my life is miserable and I have more
stress than ever never taken that call
and so how much student loans do you
have I'm just curious
um 176. okay and what is the household
income
so this last year we met a little over
200k and I think we're both on track to
earn a little bit more
um both of us so awesome we get around
220 230. so just crunching the numbers
with him and showing him using the debt
snowball method you're going all right
we make we're going to make 230. we have
176. how much of that can we allocate
towards our debt and once you go all
right we could do out of the 230 we
could throw 120 at the debt what would
that do 10 grand a month at this debt
means we're done with this thing in 18
months
instead of 20 years now I start to get
excited and you start to Crunch the
numbers and go what would what could we
do if we had that money freed up how
could we invest how could we send our
kids to college debt free
what vacations could we go on and that
starts to get you guys dreaming because
right now it's all about the present and
survival I want you to get a vision for
the future what does the next five years
look like 10 years look like how what is
an early retirement look like
and so start talking and ask him say
what are your goals what does the future
look like for you and that will get you
guys actually excited about doing this
plan so it's not just well Megan got a
hold of this Ramsay stuff and she just
wants to get out of debt because Dave
said that's never true that's right but
I'm telling you the fact that George is
gifting you uh financial piece if you
can just get the hubs to go with you I
mean and just let him sit among other
people other couples and begin to see
how this process works out you don't
have to sell him on anything hopefully
he'll see the light yeah and generally
by lesson two the switch turns I think
that's right yeah we got to do this yeah
I'm on fire to do this now and I'm
cheering you on Megan I know it's tough
I know what you're feeling and I'm glad
that you're willing to have the
conversation that's the hardest part the
fact that you're willing to have that
conversation and that he's willing to
listen willing to do the budget I'm so
proud of you guys so hang on the line
Austin's gonna pick up and we're going
to get you those resources and you call
us back if you need anything maybe he'll
call that would be fun Ken I don't think
we've got a fine a follow-up call from
the husband I like that you know I like
that a lot I like that but the big
shovel helps and that's something that
can you help people do every day and
while you have the pile of student loans
yes it helps when you make 2 30 and
you're actually willing to make use of
it yeah let me just give you some
positive news because you'll hear a lot
of negative thanks folks listen now is
one of the greatest times in our
country's history to make side money
the gig economy uh freelancing I'm
telling you if you want to make more
money it is out there waiting on you go
do it love it hey this puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books it has been
our pleasure I'm George Campbell he's
Ken Coleman on behalf of the entire team
here at Ramsey and all the folks in the
booth we appreciate you guys listening
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]